The view contains three
sets of elements.
The first element is the toolbar,
now styled in white.
The second set is a view
reminiscent of the Today view.
And the third set contains
additional weather detail.
Some quick measurement shows that
the top set of Today elements is one and
a half times the height of the bottom
half of the detail elements.
Sounds like a job for
a LinearLayout with weights.
Inside of the sets, we see some
interesting Android layout techniques.
Two spacer views are in place above and
below that vertically center
the content of the Today styled view.
Following the rules of material design,
we see 16dp spacers being used
liberally in the vertical direction,
along with 32dp spacers in the
horizontal direction for the details.
But we're still missing
the core of these layouts.
It would be pretty easy to build the top
one with a nested LinearLayout, and
slightly tricky with a RelativeLayout.
But it turns out that both of
these sections are built with only
one layout each, a GridLayout.
GridLayout was added to Android for
the Ice Cream Sandwich release.
Its goal is to address the limitations
of Android's nested layouts,
which fall into three basic categories.
Firstly, the inability
to control alignment
along both axes simultaneously.
Performance problems in
hierarchies that are too deep,
especially when you're using expensive
features such as layout_weight.
And unsuitability for design tools
that support freeform editing.
And yes, we are looking at you,
RelativeLayout.
As its name suggests, GridLayout uses
rows and columns to layout views.
You can see it adjust the grid
automatically as controls in
the righthand column get larger.
Using GridLayout,
you give constraints to each view,
as well as specify what to do
with the extra space in the cell,
using the GridLayout's own
version of layout_gravity.
The GridLayout then attempts to preserve
the constraints as it solves the problem
of laying out the view.
Android Lollipop added the ability to
GridLayout to reapportion space among
its child's views automatically
using layout_weights.
Fortunately, the support library
let's us use this latest and
greatest version of GridLayout.
GridLayout is a separate
support component.
It requires a separate entry in
your Gradle dependency list.
Here are a bunch of layout
elements in no particular layout.
If we place the layouts into a default
GridLayout, it behaves similar to
LinearLayout, although it aligns
text to the baseline by default.
We didn't have to put the height or
width of each into the layout XML
because GridLayout assumes wrap content.
Here is the underlying grid
produced by this layout.
Changing the orientation to vertical
makes it perform very similar to
a vertical LinearLayout.
And here is the grid
produced by that layout.
Changing things back to the default
orientation of horizontal, but
giving the GridLayout
a column count of two,
causes GridLayout to automatically
place the child views into columns.
Here's the underlying grid
produced by this layout.
Explicitly setting the icon view to the
second layout row, first layout column
causes the GridLayout to move the cloud
icon to the first column in the second
row and continue laying out
all other views from there.
Here's the underlying grid
produced by this layout.
But even better,
we can use layout_columnSpan to have
the date span both of the columns.
Here's the underlying grid
produced by that layout.
Now we can distribute the extra
weight across all columns by adding
a layout_columnWeight
to all of the columns.
Note that you need to add this to all
layouts in the column in each row for
it to have the desired effect.
And here's the underlying
grid produced by this layout.
We can tell the GridLayout to center
a view horizontally within its cell
by adding layout_gravity
equals center_horizontal.
By adding this to each layout,
we get this effect.
Note that the two columns
aren't exactly even,
because we only distributed
the extra weight between them.
It looks close because they
contain similar sized elements.
You can really see that in
the grid produced by this layout.
Material Design defines
these default styles.
These sizes and styles were developed
to balance content density and
reading comfort under
typical usage conditions.
Consider using these styles
whenever possible as
it will help you make
good design decisions.
The support library provides
the definitions for
all of these font styles.
Here's how you would reference
the Display 4 112sp style in
the textAppearance of a TextView.
We're going to do our best to make
sunshine use as many of these styles
as we can while implementing
the new design.